In this video, we'll
finally look at the, uh,
expression for the dividends of the last
function with respect to the parameters
in our neural network. So
we're finally ready to, uh,
get the expression for,
uh,
the great end of the last function with
respect to the parameters that we need
to, uh, apply these to castic
gradient descent out with
them for training a neural
network.
Yeah.
So let's first look at the partial it
is with respect to the weights. So, uh,
so when we are looking at the partial,
the they've for the weight I j uh,
for the hidden layer, Kay. So
one of the parcel with this, uh,
the loss function.
Now I'm the only pre activation that
depends on this weight is going to be
deeply activation at the hidden
layer k for the IMF hidden unit.
So Wij or k Ij is going to
connect that hidden unit with the,
uh,
hidden unit below in the using its
activation for the GF hidden unit that the
layer below.
So using the chain rule,
we can write that partial derivative
as the product of the partial.
They'll live up the last function with
respect to deeply activation at the kid
hidden layer for hidden unit.
I times the partial native of that active,
that pre activation with
respect to our parameter.
And now we know that the reactivation
is a linear function with respect to the
weight.
So it's a linear transformation of the
activation of the hidden layer below and
now in this son.
So the gradient,
which respect Wij for the
[inaudible] layer of this term,
the biases zero,
this does not depend on the weights.
And here we have a some that involves
a bunch of different weights,
but the only one that matters that is a,
that involves Wij is the one for the value
of j that corresponds to this j here.
And so, uh, here, then
we'll have this parameter.
So the parameter multiply by
the activation of the JFK,
then unit at the layer below.
So if we take the narratives,
a narrative of that wear
suits back to Wk Ij, uh,
we just get a,
the activation value.
So this is just equal to the activation
of the JFF hidden unit in the hidden
layer. That's just below the
hidden layer came my last one.
Yeah.
And uh, now, uh, so we just take
that and we multiply it by the, uh,
pre activation,
a partial derivative,
which we've seen before. We've
seen how to uh, wishing a form.
We've seen the formula for,
okay,
now what if we want the gradient.
So if on the grain and
with respect to a matrix,
then that's going to be instead of being
a of partial data live is going to be a
matrix of partial dividends where the
elements I Jay is going to be the partial
derivative with respect to
Wij for day Keith in layer,
if you go back in the expression,
we see that this parcel,
the four elements at row I n column j
is a just a multiplication of the pre
activation,
a partial David dative for neuron.
I times the value,
the activation value of the neuron,
uh,
for the JF neuron at the layer below.
So what we can do is take the vector
of a pre activation gradients.
So that's uh, that's what the
grain in vector is going to be.
The vector of partial. That
is for all potential, uh,
p activation in the layer cake.
And then multiply that by the vector
of activations at the layer below.
But we're going to transpose
it to get a row vector.
Now if we take a column
vector times a row vector,
we're going to get a matrix
and d element at position.
I,
a row I n Colin Jay is simply going to
be the IAFF elements of the column Vector
Times Djf elements of the row vector.
And so indeed we'll get a matrix where
the element Ij is going to be the
multiplication of the ASM and of that
vector times DJF element of that vector,
which turns out to be,
uh,
the actual value of the partial data
with this Spec to connection I Jay.
So we get this expression actually does
correspond to the gradients with respect
to the full matrix w for
the hidden layer cake.
And, uh, now we can look at the partial
that is with respect to the biases.
Uh, so again, the uh,
only pre activation that depends on the
IMF bias for the hidden layer cake is
going to be deeply activation for hidden
layer gay looking at it's hidden unit.
So we can take with the chain rule
that partial there they have time,
the partial [inaudible] of that pre
activation for the eye, uh, hitting unit,
hidden layer k with respect
to our parameter. And uh,
looking at this formula, we see that
this term does not depend on the bias,
but this term depends on it. And uh,
it's actually just that variable.
So if we think the partial derivative,
which respected that is going to be one.
So this term multiplied by that,
just essentially cancel this
out because it's equal to one.
So we only get the value of the partial
daily of the pre activation for the IMF
hidden unit.
Any food put that into a vector.
Well that's just the gradients
for the p activation.
So actually the gradient
for the bias for the hidden,
they are k,
it's just a gradient for the reactivation.
So it's actually very simple.
So with that,
we have an expression for the grain is
for all of our weights and all our biases
that we need to use to apply
stochastic gradient descent,
training of neural networks.